ومعنا الان من شرق اوكرانيا المتحدث باسم
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في الجبهه
الشرقيه
شرفياتي اهلا وسهلا بك معنا في التاسعه
واريد ان اسالك عن تصريحات السابقه هذا
اليوم كنت تحدثت فيها عن عدم استبعاد
الانسحاب من ضخمه هل حسم الامر بهذا
الخصوص
نحن حتى الان باقيين في باخموت ومستمرين
في الدفاع عن في المناطق الغربيه من
المدينه عدا عن ذلك نحن
نتقدم جنوبا وشمالا في المدينه
واستطعنا ان نسيطر على ما يزيد من 200 متر
في هذه الاجنحه كذلك نقوم بشكل مستمر
بتوجيه ضربات ضد العدو ونقوم بتدمير
اعضائه
وقمنا بجرح 160 وقتلنا بعضهم
وقمنا بثلاثه عشر هجمه صاروخيه دمرنا فيها
بعض
المستودعات والمدافع
وقمنا بتدمير مدرعات مسيره ولكن العدو كما
سميته انت يعتبر ان الموضوع قد حسم على
الاقل بالنسبه لم
الك
باك هو يعتبر ان هناك
جهات عديده من المدينه قد تم الاستيلاء
عليها
وسيتم تسليمها للجيش الروسي كيف يفهم هذا
في الواقع في هذه الاعلانات اهم شيء هو ما
يعلنه انه سيطره وهذا ما اعتدنا على سماعه
قمنا بتدمير
باجزاء كبيره وخلال ثماني ثمانيه اشهر
ونصف قمنا بتدمير هذه المنظمه وهم يحاولوا
ان يجدوا عذرا يسمح لهم بالهروب من باخموت
وهذا السبب
الاعلان من قبل السيد فاقدر الذي قال
بالسيد بريجوجل الذي قال ان المدينه غير
صالحه لاجراء معارك فيها الان حيث القوات
الاوكرانيه نحن نحاول التقدم وهم يحاولوا
ان يكبروا من احجام ما حققوه وسوف نرى ما
سوف يحدث في القط اع يعني محاولات استمرت
لمده ثمانيه اشهر واسالك لماذا تتمسك
القوات الاوكرانيه بهذه المدينه تحديدا
رغم ان هناك جهات مختلفه من بينها جهه
امريكيه تقلل من اهميتها الاستراتيجيه
في الواقع
هذا الدفاع الذي نقوم به طوالي حوالي تسع
اشهر
والكثيرين ممن فقدوه في فاجنر وبعض
الجنرالات في الواقع
حوالي
الساقطين من قبل القوات الروسيه حوالي 100
الف جندي وهذه اعداد كبيره لحرب مثل هذا
مثل هذه الحرب
لانر هي قوات خاصه هجوميه وكما قلت ان
النتيجه في هذه المعارك اننا دمرنا قوات
فاغنر وهي عمود مهم في القوات الروسيه في
الاوقات التي قمنا باستنزافهم فيها في
الحدود الداخليه الاوكرانيه قمنا بتجهيز
الاف من الجنود والمعدات الاوكرانيه التي
سوف تكون جاهزه
للانضمام للمعارك في باخمه ضد العدو الذي
تم استنزافه وسوف يتم طرده خارج الحدود
الاوكرانيه
كيف تختلف المعادله الميدانيه بين مواجهه
قوات فاجنر ومواجهه القوات
الروسيه النظاميه
وايضا كيف يؤثر هذا على اولوياتكم انتم في
القوات الاوكرانيه
في الواقع روسيا في بدايه الربيع اعلنت
انهم سوف يقوموا بهجمات قويه وفي الواقع
هذه الهجمات فشلت في جميع الجبهات والخطوط
في خاركوف وفي لوغانست لم نسمح لهم
بالقيام باي هجمات حيث تقوم بهذه العمليات
القوات الرسميه الروسيه ولقد قتلنا الكثير
منهم والان في هذا الوقت
اثبتت انها قوه موحده قادره على ان تقود
بعض
المعارك لانهم يجبرون الجنود تحت تهديد ان
يتقدموا لذلك قبل شهرين قلت
انهم اذا لم يجدوا مصدرا لتعبئه اعدادهم
من الجنود واذا فقدوا هذه الاعداد الكبيره
حوالي 100 الف جندي اذا خسروا هذه الاعداد
اذا خلال شهرين سوف يفقد جميع قدراتهم من
ذلك اليوم مر شهر ونصف والان بدات فاغنر
ان تقول انهم ينسحبوا من المدينه لانهم
سيطروا عليهم ولكن في الواقع انتهى عدد
جنودهم
اشكرك السيد
سيرجياتيا المتحدث باسم القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في الجبهه الشرقيه شكرا على
وجودك معنا